the violence in Hong Kong entered a
dangerous new phase as pro-democracy
demonstrators entered their twelfth week
protesters and police clashed repeatedly
over the weekend rainy Inocencio was in
Hong Kong where he's been reporting on
these protests since they started good
morning good morning last night we saw
the most aggressive violence in weeks
right here protesters threw bricks and
Molotov cocktails trying to provoke the
police and they did beaten and chased by
a mob of protesters police fired the
first shot of these protests a warning
into the air saying later they felt
their lives were in danger hand guns
drawn they push back the rushing crowd
and kicked an older man on his knees who
begged them not to shoot also new to the
street two water cannons deployed to the
residential district of chinlock where
protesters and police clashed in a
closed standoff for hours now that the
water cannons have hit the streets
protesters have fled into the alleys all
around us after nightfall groups of
masked protesters once again used the
subways to fan out quickly attacking and
retreating before police could arrive
they smashed toll booths at across
Harvard tunnel destroyed shops thought
to be owned by China League gangs and
blocked major roads authorities seemed
unable or unwilling to stop the violence
the latest payoffs in this one stable
Asian financial hub that shows no signs
of stopping police say they arrested
three dozen people last night the
youngest just 12 years old pro-beijing
legislators have said the violence is
now life-threatening many fear people
could die that's adding to fears that
Beijing could deploy troops to pacify
this already embattled city for CBS this
morning
ramie Inocencio Hong Kong yes we're
getting worse thank you Raymond